des milliers de paires la relier entre
elles sur un buste humain on penserait
presque à un bijou cette créature est un
serveur un mélange entre un centaure la
créature mythologique et insère un vrai
julien mais l'imaginaire et le
réel les perles et la taxidermie sa
force les gens à se positionner ce qu'en
fait ils ont le choix entre les deux
extrêmes
moi je suis pas là pour donner des
messages je suis juste là pour donner
aux gens la possibilité se positionner
eux-mêmes dans leur propre imaginaire
pour moi cette pièce était un petit peu
celle qui me permettait de deux pauses
et de matières de manière un petit peu
ce culturel
la question qui était de savoir comment
est-ce qu'on peut être à la fois la
proie est le prédateur
ce travail autour de la nature l'artiste
plasticien le puise dans son héritage
familial
julien salo a été élevé dans la
contemplation des animaux sauvages mais
il se passionne aussi sur les croyances
et légendes que se créent les humains
comme ces yourtes inspiré des peuples
chaman chez eux en fait le corps il est
pas il est pas imperméable y'a pas à
l'intérieur et l'extérieur
il ya des jeux qui se jouent entre du
coup dans cette tour tant qu' couverte
avec des peaux de mouton et puis dépôt
de chevreuil vous avez 2
deux trous qui vous permettent de voir à
l'intérieur tout une installation en
fils tendus et en cloud éclairées à la
lumière noire
pour moi ce travail est un petit peu en
rapport avec avec la poésie des étoiles
on va dire donc c'est comme si en
regardant à l'intérieur du corps on
pouvait voir les étoiles qui sont les
éléments les plus lointains
une réflexion sur la violence de la mort
de l'animal exposé au sein d'un château
où les grands de l'histoire française se
retrouvaient pour chasser un bestiaire
fantasmagorique où l'artiste installe
une pointe de poésie